[Musique]
la scène du film cinéma paradiso ou
philippe noiret tourner le projecteur de
la petite salle de cinéma du village
vers les murs de la cité pour que le
maximum de gens puissent voir le film a
sans nul doute inspiré les jeunes
français vincent hanrion depuis trois
ans il parcourt à vélo les zones les
plus reculés du globe pour amener le
cinéma là où il est absent il suffit que
le public [ __ ] sur mon vélo que moi je
[ __ ] sur mon vélo on revient à
l'électricité qui après bye fallait
trouver le bon projecteurs le bon
système sont bons c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
j'installe le matériel les gens viennent
à tour de rôle pédaler sur le vélo puis
tant que les gens pédales il ya du
cinéma maintenant au bout de deux
minutes s'ils s'arrêtent de pédaler ya
tout qui s'arrête
m
ça
donne une thématique assez aventure là
et la dernière thématique sur le tour du
sénégal ça a été l'environnement donc on
a choisi des films en dialecte sur des
problématiques environnementales grâce à
l'eau angie access l'agriculture en fin
de soirée on diffuse plutôt des films de
divertissement une ouverture culturelle
aussi sur d'autres univers hélas qu'on
aimerait bien maintenant c'est de
pouvoir mixer des films de différentes
cultures
donc il peut y avoir de pourrait très
bien y avoir des films par exemple sur
les communautés autochtones du québec
diffusée au sénégal et inversement
[Musique]
première sortie vélo a été vraiment
choix j'ai eu cette attaque de chien à
40 km sur cette attaque un à trois qui
ont failli me coûter un mollet à chaque
fois je m'en suis sorti mais je me suis
dit imaginer à l'échelle de 3000 km
pendant six mois c'est obligé je me
faire croquer
[Musique]
l'idée d'emmener le cinéma dehors
d'aller à la rencontre du public de
projeter sur des bâtiments de projeter
sur nous on a une petite toile qu'on
peut plier qui à la base est une tente
mais c'est exceptionnel quand je regarde
quand je regardais les les projections
de films au sénégal que j'organisais je
voyais tous ces gens habillés de plein
de belles couleurs qui se tenait en
plein milieu de la forêt puis qu'il ya
sept cet écran blanc là au milieu de la
forêt qui s'anime
je trouve ça simplement magique
depuis sa création l'association ciné
cyclo a parcouru 21 mille kilomètres et
rejoint 24 mille spectateurs
sa devise si tu ne vas pas au cinéma le
cinéma viendra à toi ici robert frosi
radio canada montréal